♪♪
Let's get to the news.
President Biden
is set to deliver
his first State of the Union
address on March 1st,
and it's the first one where
"union" is the only good news.
Republican senator
Lindsey Graham yesterday
criticized
President Biden's speech
commemorating
the January 6th Capitol attack,
and said Biden had
"politicized the event."
How do you politicize an event
that's already political?
They stormed the Capitol,
not a Best Buy on Black Friday.
That's like saying,
"Is it just me,
or is the priest's sermon today
all about religion?
We get it. We get it."
In a speech last week
commemorating
the one-year anniversary
of the Capitol attack,
President Biden criticized
the rioters and said,
"You can't love your country
only when you win."
Well, I guess some people
are just never meant
to fall in love.
Advisors to
former President Trump
reportedly believe that
a recent improvement
in Trump's favorability rating
is due to his diminished
social media presence,
and at this point,
Biden will try anything.
Scientists are currently
disputing a new study
that claims to have discovered
a so-called
"deltacron" strain
of the coronavirus
that combines
the delta and omicron variants,
and the only thing that can
stop it is the Pfizerna vaccine.
Scientists in England
recently announced
that they've named
a type of tree
after actor Leonardo DiCaprio,
and it's currently dating
a sapling.
A little tree humor,
for everybody out there
who's into that kind of thing.
New York Mayor Eric Adams
is facing criticism
over his recent decision
to appoint his brother
to serve as
the deputy police commissioner.
Said Adams,
"Cool. Take it up with my son."
I'm gonna say it right now --
I think this Mayor Adams thing
is off to a great start --
insofar as, you know,
monologue jokes.
Hot start.
Don't want to jinx it.
Mercedes-Benz recently unveiled
its new
all-electric concept car,
which is made from
several sustainable materials,
can travel 620 miles
on a single charge,
and takes up two parking spots.
BlackBerry last week officially
stopped supporting
its line of
signature mobile devices.
Of course,
I was totally prepared,
because I set a reminder
on my PalmPilot.
And finally, Taco Bell
announced its so-called
"Taco Lover's Pass"
subscription service last week,
which costs $10 a month
to receive one taco per day
for 30 consecutive days.
On the downside,
"Taco Lovers Pass"
will also be the headline
of their obituary.
Now that's the kind of joke
you can do, you know,
when you're
in an empty apartment.
You don't have to worry
about the groans.
Right?
Tell the jokes you want to tell
about Taco Bell.
What do you mean,
who am I taking to?
Who are you talking to?
According to a new survey,
just 9% of Americans said
that the Biden administration
is doing a great job handling
the omicron coronavirus strain.
I assume it's the same 9%
who don't currently have it.
Oh, you're cocky now.
But it's coming.
According to a new poll,
President Biden's
overall disapproval rating
hit a new high last month,
or as his aides are phrasing it,
"Your numbers are way up, sir."
The CDC is reportedly
considering updating
its coronavirus guidance
to recommend that people
wear N95 or KN95 masks
or, barring that, just 95 masks.
The CDC also issued a
do-not-travel advisory yesterday
for Canada due to an increase
in coronavirus cases there,
which is kind of
like Keith Richards
telling you not to hang around
with that pothead from school.
According to new reports,
Senate Democrats have grown
tired of trying to convince
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin
to support
a federal elections bill
and complained that it's "like
negotiating via Etch A Sketch."
Which begs the question,
have you tried shaking him yet?
The federal government
has reportedly approved Facebook
for hundreds of new patents
over the last few months
for augmented
and virtual reality technology
they've created.
It's great for escaping
this hellish actual reality
which they also created.
The makers of Goldfish have
unveiled a new type of cracker
that's 50% bigger
than the original snack
and specifically made
for adults.
Please, I'm a grown man.
I'm not gonna eat Goldfish.
I just had two string cheeses
and a Fruit Roll-Up,
and my tummy's a mess.
According to a new documentary,
"Playboy" founder
Hugh Hefner's pet poodle
was addicted to cocaine,
though according to my eyes,
all of them are.
That's right, Hugh Hefner's
poodle was addicted to cocaine,
which explains why he was
so afraid of the vacuum cleaner.
"No! My stash!"
Yeah, dogs -- dogs on cocaine
sound like Samberg.
That's just science.
And finally, Tesla recently
released a new version
of its self-driving software
that allows drivers to select
among three different
aggression profiles,
including chill, average,
or New Jersey Turnpike.
And I'm hearing -- Really?
Was the 1 millionth
monologue joke
with the punch line
"New Jersey Turnpike."
Across all talk shows,
since the history of talk shows.
And is that true?
I'm gonna get a $10
E-ZPass credit for that.
So, ha-ha,
things are looking up.
During a speech yesterday
in Atlanta,
President Biden endorsed
changing the Senate filibuster
in order to pass federal
voting rights legislation
and said, "I'm tired
of being quiet."
Quiet?
When did we ever say
we wanted a quiet president?
Oh, right. Okay, yeah.
Yeah, we may have
put it out there.
During a hearing yesterday,
Republican Senator Richard Burr
criticized the
Biden Administration's
coronavirus pandemic messaging
and said that the American
people are "confused."
Said Biden, "It's simple.
Just wear a mask indoors.
Unless you're indoors,
and then you can
safely make outdoors indoors
so long as your booster stays
six feet away
from sheltering in place."
Come on, Jack!
A new op-ed
in "The Wall Street Journal"
suggests that Hillary Clinton
could be the best
Democratic nominee for the 2024
presidential election,
because all voters
really want right now
is someone who admits it
when they lose.
The House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
has subpoenaed two advisers
to Donald Trump Jr.
to try to find out
what exactly it is that they do.
Former President Trump
reportedly hung up
on NPR journalist
Steve Inskeep yesterday
just 9 minutes
into a 15-minute interview.
Though, to be fair, who among us
hasn't tapped out 9 minutes
into a 15-minute NPR segment?
I say that as a fan.
Been there.
Former Democratic presidential
hopefuls Andrew Yang
and Marianne Williamson
had dinner on Monday
in New York City.
"Please, no photos,"
said the restaurant.
Kellogg's recently released
a Valentine's Day-themed
Froot Loops cereal that
includes heart-shaped pieces.
But if that's
what she wants this year,
she's too young for you, dude!
Does it look like
I'm looking at him?
Listen, you guys know,
in reality,
I'm just looking at a wall.
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
turned 58 years old today.
If you want to wish him a happy
birthday, just say it out loud.
I'm sure one of your devices
will get the message to him.
Pope Francis visited
a record shop in Rome yesterday
and left with a CD.
And I gotta say,
I didn't even realize
the Popemobile had visors.
Two of our writers
wrote that joke.
Which is weird,
because all of our writers
are 22 or younger.
And, finally... [ Laughs ]
And finally, the Girl Scouts
have partnered with
the delivery platform DoorDash
to allow local troops
to sell cookies through the app.
Meanwhile, the Boy Scouts?
Still trying to make a fire
with sticks.
They develop slower.
It's just a boy/girl thing.
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell yesterday
called President Biden's speech
in Georgia on voting rights
"profoundly unpresidential."
Oh, I'm sorry -- is that
something we still track?
What should he have said?
Voting is only for 9s and above?
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
has reportedly found a loophole
that will allow Democrats
to bypass
a Republican filibuster
on a new voting rights bill.
All he had to do to find it
was push his glasses up
to their normal height.
"Oh! There it is!"
Confidants of former
Vice President Mike Pence
reportedly believe
that he is preparing
to run for president in 2024,
though I think he's just in it
for the security detail.
Amid accusations of nepotism,
it was announced yesterday
that New York Mayor Eric Adams
has demoted his brother
from deputy police commissioner
to executive director
of mayoral security.
Still not as bad
as when Mayor Giuliani
gave his cousin the job of wife.
During a speech --
Sometimes you're bummed
that there's not
an audience around.
During a speech yesterday
on the Senate floor,
Republican Senator Marco Rubio
described the life
of a typical liberal
as watching MSNBC,
morning Peloton bike rides,
drinking caramel macchiatos,
and eating avocado toast.
Are you kidding me?
Do you know how many calories
are in a caramel macchiato?
I'm not gonna throw away
my Peloton ride like that.
Supreme Court heard
oral arguments on Tuesday,
and Justice Neil Gorsuch
was reportedly
the only member
not to wear a face mask.
Even worse, they're letting him
play in the Australian Open.
An ex-girlfriend of Republican
congressman Matt Gaetz
reportedly testified yesterday
before a federal grand jury.
After being thanked
for cooperating, she said,
"Hey, anything to get out
of gym class."
Organizers of the annual
Toy Fair New York trade show
canceled the event this week
for the second year in a row
amid a rise
in coronavirus cases,
which is for the best because
they were about to launch
the new Cough On Me Elmo.
Three men were arrested
in New York recently
after they allegedly
impersonated police officers
to rob a suspected drug dealer
of more than $150,000
and 3 kilograms of cocaine.
Even crazier, the suspected
drug dealer who called the cops.
"Yeah, I'd like to report
a robbery of some, uh...
various items."
Actress Megan Fox
and musician Machine Gun Kelly
announced their engagement
yesterday
and said they drank
each other's blood.
That's right --
he got down on one knee,
then two knees,
then passed out from blood loss.
And finally,
according to a new study,
exercising for 20 minutes a day
can reduce the risk
of developing dementia.
Finally, conclusive evidence
that golf is not exercise.
♪♪